estoy cerca de esta parte occidental de
berlín cerca de la muy conocida calle
kürfürstendamm donde ocurrió este
incidente hace unas horas la policía ha
tratado de informar de los últimos
detalles y ha asegurado que una persona
murió varios heridos algunos de gravedad
a policía sin embargo no a freno se
prefirió no dar detalles concretos sobre
cuántas personas están heridas y cuántas
de gravedad lo que sí informaron es que
lograron detener al conductor lo están
están hablando con él están tratando de
decidir también si necesita atención
médica y como ocurre con frecuencia en
estos casos y yo he cubierto varios de
sus casos aquí en alemania la policía se
abstiene de mencionar cuál podría ser la
motivación detrás de este incidente
también pidiéndoles a las personas que
no especulen por el momento entonces no
se sabe claramente cuál sería la
motivación detrás de esta persona lo que
sí se sabe y explicó la policía es que
el conductor un hombre relativamente
joven en un carro pequeño o sea no se
trata de un camión o de un carro grande
atropello esa multitud en la parte
comercial del occidente de berlín hasta
que chocó también con un almacén y fue
precisamente tras ese choque en el
almacén que la policía pudo detener al
presunto atacante y por el momento aquí
en alemania están esperando que se
conozcan más informaciones para conocer
no solamente cuántas personas
exactamente han resultado heridas y cuál
es su estado de gravedad sino también
por supuesto el tema de la motivación
que es uno que genera bastante
preocupación aquí en alemania